packed with clever callbacks and cameos
The Walking Dead gave fans one hell of a
ride in its 11 Seasons here's the hidden
stuff only the most dedicated viewer
notice in the iconic series
from the first few minutes of The
Walking Dead pilot it's clear that this
series is not just another zombie story
and not just because the show makes a
point to stay away from the Z word the
Walkers are treated as people and every
one of their deaths and deaths and even
their second deaths hit characters close
to home Rick Grimes meets his first
Walker and she's just a little girl
complete with braces and a teddy bear
little girl
I'm a policeman
when he puts her down he feels it and so
do fans The Walker that known only as
little girl Walker was played by actress
Addie Miller when The Walking Dead
reached its season 8 premiere the
showrunners decided to one in the series
earliest moments and cast Miller again
now grown up as another Walker her new
Walker is built from callbacks she has
the same crisscross scar on her right
forehead and the same open deformed
right cheek the novel's a fun one
especially when you consider how it
implies that Walkers still age develop
and even have their braces removed hey
zombies gotta see a dentist too in the
season 1 episode vatos the Survivor
group as we told Dale about the watch he
always wears and consistently whines I
see you every day
same time
winding that thing like a village priest
saying mass since the world has come
more or less to an end the group asked
Dale what UC has for time keeping in
response Dale defenses temporal fixation
by reinterpreting a passage from William
Faulkner's the sound and the theory he
half quotes and half positives that the
watch is a mausoleum of all hope and
desire and that its importance is not
that you may remember time but that you
may forget it for a moment now and then
and not spend all of your breath trying
to conquer it the speech is an important
one for the overarching theme of the
series it touches on the need to accept
one's present circumstances instead of
being ruled by regrets and hypotheticals
and it suggests that those who are
trapped by time are the true dead ones
not the unburdened Walkers the message
possessed at least through the end of
season 5 which ends with five episodes
titled remember forget spend try and
conquer the five words in a row
represent five important points in
Dale's speech in the same order
The Walking Dead is the troyers for its
blinking your midst and references to
other franchises characters and actors
some like Johnny Depp's Cameo are simply
slightly users of props or cheeky
special effects sometimes however actual
celebrities make their way into the show
hidden under pounds of fake blood and
Rotting Flesh shuffling around in the
background stiffly lurching toward
nowhere the season 9 episode scars
featured Chris Hardwick as a walker
clumsily pouring Judith legendary
Anthrax guitarist Scott Ian appeared in
remember as a walker who had costs
wrecking Carl long time voice and
character actor MC Gainey played a
walker in Slabtown All-Star Pittsburgh
Steeler Heinz Ward took a turn as a
walker in the suicide King even series
executive producer director and special
effects supervisor Greg nicotero dons
the Walker makeup for the episode Hunted
wherein he rips a chunk out of Agatha's
arm after 11 seasons and over 150
episodes The Walking Dead has accrued a
serious collection of bad guys and gals
one group of the Wolves has a
distinction of foreshadowing their
arrival more poetically than all the
others I don't get to meet
new people very often
though the walls didn't emerge as main
antagonists until season six the show's
production team used season 5 to
establish the Wolves bloodthirstiness
cruelty and their penchant for ironic
literary Illusions in the season 5
episode conquer Dowell and Aaron spot a
man walking alone through a field
sporting a bright red Poncho and Hood
though the pair lose track of the red
Poncho man as he is officially known
viewers are shown his ultimate fate
later in the same episode The Wolves
brutally murder the red Poncho man the
reference was not lost on viewers after
all there's been at least one other
literary confrontation between a
red-headed human and a vicious wolf
Mercy was a Show's 100th episode and as
such is filled with fun references
reveling and reminding viewers of times
past parrots has lost and more the
episode is packed with shot for shot
copies of shots from the pilot just like
in the pilot Rick comes to in a hospital
bed and rolls over to ponder of ours of
flowers at his bedside at this time
however the flowers are in bloom and
much of the pilot sequence where Rick
searches for gas and surveys a record of
the gas station and Highway is repeated
in Mercy as well though Carl Now
searches and his father's dead
series bigwig Greg nicotero very
purposefully laced season 9 with
references to one of his favorite film
franchises which is also one of his
first gigs the Evil Dead films there's
something out there
lives out in those woods in season 9
episode 5 what comes after which was the
last appearance of series lead Rick
Grimes two distinct nods to the cold
horror classics can be seen when the
heavily injured wreck escapes a zombie
horde he takes refuge in a dilapidated
abandoned cabin the cabin exterior is a
close replica of the cabin from 1981's
the evil dead and 1987's Evil Dead 2.
Inside Rick spots are mounted deer head
the same one that came to life in Evil
Dead 2. as well as the evil grimoire
that launched the franchise's whole
story the Necronomicon speaking with
Entertainment Weekly nicotero confirms
that the references were no coincidence
easily one of the most iconic and
enjoying scenes of all of The Walking
Dead happens and the day will come when
you won't be when Negan murders Abraham
and Glenn Glenn's death was perhaps the
show's most gruesome moment I know it
was devastated because I I love that
show and Glenn was like one of my
favorite characters the scene made such
an impression that Dave Chappelle
spoofed it when hosting Saturday Night
Live the horrific scene was made even
worse by the fact that Glenn's wife
Maggie was forced to watch helpless to
stop her viewers were reminded of
Maggie's pain two years later in the
season 9 episode the bridge in the
bridge we see the interior of Maggie's
office in the Barrington house at the
hilltop settlement one of her walls is
covered in colorful expressionist
portraits six of which can be seen
clearly and has painted the pieces for
Maggie and each portrait is a loved one
Maggie has lost including her father
Herschel sister Beth and her daily
departed husband Glenn season 10
features one of the show's most
tantalizing nods to the comic series and
potential foreshadowing beginning in
episode 9 squeeze in the episode The
Whisperer leader Alpha comes on to Negan
offering sex for negan's help wary Negan
asks her this isn't some sort of a
praying mantis situation as if they cut
off my head afterwards this is an
understandable question on the surface
as Alpha could kill whomever she wanted
at a moment's notice but readers of the
comic series knew that this line
contained a deeper meaning in the comics
the roles are reversed and Negan
actually Cuts Alpha's head off fans
didn't have to wait long to find out if
this was simply a winter comic readers
or actual foreshadowing the truth was
made clear three episodes later in walk
with us in which Negan does indeed kill
Alpha by cutting off her head in a
subtle and slanted way his praying
mantis remark was him calling his shots
as he said just before murdering Glenn
now I don't know what kind of lie and
[__] you've been doing dealing with
but I'm a man of my word and season nine
is what comes after series protagonist
Rick leaves the show for good the moment
was always going to be huge as the
character was a Show's driving force and
emotional core for more than eight years
with a show like The Walking Dead so
focused on death always ready to raise
the stakes and seemingly eager to kill
off major characters many fans expected
Rick to end his run on the show with a
spectacular death scene instead a still
living wreck threw off in a helicopter
with an Mercy
prevails
over my red the helicopter that scooped
him up was later revealed to belong to
the Civic Republican military who's a
mistakable three-ring logo has shown up
at different times even Crossing into
the spin-off series via The Walking Dead
the most direct hint of Rick's existence
occurs when Michonne finds Rick's boots
in a shipwreck alongside a cell phone
upon which was drawn crude likenesses of
Michonne and Judith Rex closed its
family members the phone also featured
some Japanese characters Which Walking
Dead overlords Scott's gimple confirmed
translated to believe a little bit
longer while we have to wait a little
longer fans got a tease setting up a
Rick Grimes and Michonne spin-off at the
end of The Walking Dead series finale
more than anything else Walking Dead
fans were desperate for one return in
the series finale a certain Grimes man
who's been absent for multiple Seasons
now although Carl died in season 8
episode 9 the actor who played him
Chandler Riggs made an appearance in the
final episode Riggs makes a long
anticipated background Cameo as a farmer
what were you expecting to see Rick
again well yes both fan favorites Rick
and Michonne return teasing the future
of The Walking Dead franchise as a whole
but more importantly we got a Sly return
from Rex all grown up in an interview
with ew showrunner Angela Kang revealed
the surprising Simplicity of Rigg's
return saying he was in town and he just
asked a visit to say hi to friends and
then they were doing these scenes and
needed some extras and Greg nicotero was
like well you want to go for it get in
there go get in the back a scene in
question involves a handful of
characters in Hilltop including Daryl
discussing their plans for the future
while a number of colonists tend to land
in the background one of those unnamed
colonists had a name at least in another
life Carl old Grimes if you watch The
Walking Dead series finale live and
actually sat through the commercials you
were treated to a series of hilarious
advertisements for different companies
connected by one standout shambling
component all of them featured former
Walking Dead actors seemingly returned
to unlife as zombies everyone thinks
Walkers are scary you know what's even
scarier
humans the ad block is officially known
as The Walking Dead advertising or at
least that's the name chosen by its
creator Ryan Reynolds and I'd like to
present to you the world's first grunt
powered door handle
The Walking Dead advertising blog
consisted of five ads for companies
doordash Autodesk ring Deloitte and
Mountain performance TV come on man I
won't bite just kidding I totally will
each stars are zombie played by a former
Walking Dead actor easily the most
exciting was a mountain performance TV
ad in here to Lori Holden reprises her
role as Andrea Harrison one of the
series leading characters in its first
three seasons posing out her dialogue by
revealing hey Ryan Reynolds brain
for years The Walking Dead has been a
dominant force in TV drama thanks to its
complex characters Nuance moral
exploration and unyielding commitment to
the long game in the series finale the
remaining survivors among the principal
cast together for a simple wholesome
family dinner on a Sunday they chat joke
and toast each other a scene ends
without conflict or drama just a
well-earned satisfaction yet every
moment is positively drenched in irony
and a full palette of emotions thanks to
the scene that set it up all the way
back in season 7 episode 1. after the
notorious scene in which Negan murders
Ford and Glenn with a baseball bat he
gives Rick one of his characteristic
nuggets of nihilistic wisdom saying that
you thought you were all going to grow
old together sitting around the table at
Sunday dinner in the happily ever after
no doesn't work like that Rick not
anymore to add poignancy to the horror
that episode ends with a dream sequence
in which Rick imagines them all having a
nice dinner together one that was now
impossible six years later during finale
the dream becomes a reality the peaceful
dinner is real and to make it even more
impactful Negan chooses to avoid the
meal a wordless but powerful show of
regret and growth